I had no interest whatsoever in steroids
I got involved in this because in editor
who's a friend of mine called me up and
said Jose Canseco just heard this crazy
book where he said steroids are the
wonder drug of tomorrow and I said look
man I am not much of a baseball fan it
kind of bores me
and everybody knows steroids are
terrible for you because it goes out of
his mind there's no way don't like I
don't want you're wasting my time and he
said you know it was very very
convincing he said they'll pay you to do
the research and I was like absolutely
I'm in so I you know I started looking
at and I just started I said okay I'm
just gonna read I'm gonna go back ten
years and read the articles in the major
journals New England Journal Medicine
science nature that kind of thing not
even go that deep very very quickly what
I started to discover is every single
thing I thought I knew about steroids
was wrong every crazy disease these
drugs have been linked to had nothing to
do with it for I'll give you a
phenomenal example steroids were linked
to liver cancer liver problems right
nothing to do with the steroid has to do
with the coating they put around the
steroid so it could pass through the
stomach and get into your bloodstream
that was what was causing the problems
that coating obviously has since been
replaced but Nick Evans who's at UCLA is
the only person literally in history
who's ever done long term steroid
studies right long term abusers
bodybuilders double and triple stacking
steroids for 10 20 years at a time none
of the things we've been told about are
real the only danger he found is since
the heart is a muscle there's a certain
point if you're taking massive massive
doses over long periods of time it can
expand it could grow right and go bigger
bigger it's bigger than the blood
vessels and the ventricles and whatnot
which would be a problem and this
doesn't mean by the way when teenagers
use steroids right when you're still
producing lots of these substances it's
an absolute disaster right that's bad
news
but in adults everything we've been told
tends to be wrong and some of what we've
been told
cost millions of lives right
turns out steroids are phenomenal
phenomenal and fighting back aids
they're really really really good nobody
wanted to talk about it when doctors
started treating AIDS patients with it
um the guy who started doing this was a
guy named Walter Jack ah the government
jumped in and put him in jail for five
years he scared the hell out of a ton of
doctors and the result of this kind of
us trying to keep sports pure and you
know preserve the competitive advantage
has been millions of people died as a
result
so if not only is everything you've been
told about steroids wrong but there were
a lot of consequences the people who
have been on the forefront of this and
kind of pushing it forward are is the
life extension community right our
hormones decline as we age so the idea
here is we can replace them and they've
been working on this stuff for a 10-15
years at this point
with some success it is now one of five
or six different ways people are
attacking aging right and fighting back
death but one thing seems to be sure
since Google's in in the anti-death game
right Peter Diamandis my partner in in
Bouldin abundance as human longevity
incorporated there in the life extension
game there are big companies massive
amounts of resources getting involved in
steroids or a piece of this puzzle and I
think we're going to have to as a
country rethink our position on these
drugs and eight anti-aging stuff is
going to force us to do it